well hello harry and thomas hello hello
there
hello so first of all did you guys know
anything about chess prior to this show
or have you played
was it a favorite of yours me
no i didn't know anything about chess um
at all
uh and so when i sent the script and
when there was all these sort of
different moves
involved uh i didn't really know what it
was what specifically they were
they were describing but then of course
um i had to learn
very quick how to play and um more
importantly how to look like i played
for years
and that was a really brilliant and um
challenging uh
thing to to sort of get on board with
yep
thomas i played a bit um i knew what the
chess pieces did and i knew how to kind
of navigate my way through a game
but not not properly not really so i
mean when i got
um the opportunity to play this role i
went out and i
i i bought myself a a chess set and i
just
sat at home and and just got used to
moving the pieces around i realized
quite quickly that that was
the kind of the most important thing
really because you can't just kind of
teach yourself how to be a
us chess champion and then when i got on
set i realized that
everyone else that was surrounding me
that was a
champion was also focusing on that they
were saying that's
one of the most important things is how
you move pieces around
and how you touch pieces and you know
what fingers you use and
and how you take and um and that that
was the kind of the most important thing
to
kind of convey the image that we know
what we're talking about
yeah well thomas
uh thomas for you you know what was it
like taking on a character like benny
who's
you know arrogant confident unique
you know and and full of life for the
game of chess
[Music]
just comes very naturally to me
no um
it was lovely it was great um yeah i'm
normally quite a quiet person
um and i'm quite kind of naturally shy
i'd say
um so it's actually quite nice for me to
tap into that part of me that
feels okay with being that kind of
arrogantly confident
um but it's weird i mean he's he's
arrogantly confident but he doesn't come
across as a
as a dick he's yes he's a narcissist but
he's not
he's not a bad person at all yeah um
i mean it's all in the writing really i
have to put it down to the writing and
i think scott did such a great job with
that yeah um but he you know he tries
very hard to be an enigma to be
a bit of an oddball and to stand out
from the crowd because i think he enjoys
that
um very fun to play really funny yeah
yeah harry for you i mean harry playing
harry but
um i wanted i was hoping for sparks to
fly between
harry and beth how would you describe
the way harry feels about her
or thinks about her um yeah i think
it's i think when we first are
introduced to harry and
and and beth together it's at a
tournament
um it's in kentucky and he's the
champion
and i think she does quite literally
burst his bubble both
in terms of chess and in terms of the
life that i think he
thinks he's going to have and that's
kind of where
their story sort of that's sort of the
the catalyst for their story
um and like you say that um he's he
finds
beth again when she's at a very low
point in her life
and he just i just when i read it i was
really touched by his um
his generosity and uh his goodness and
how much he cares about beth
um so yeah awesome well thank you for
your time guys have a good day
you too bye bye bye